the 50 shades darker cast resumes  filming in France Jamie Dornan Dakota  Johnson and dozens of cast and crew  members have been filming the third  movie in the Fifty Shades of Grey  franchise in France Thursday the  terrible attack happened in Nice and in  fact they had spent several days  shooting seaside honeymoon scenes only  about 25 minutes from nice but luckily  cast and crew are all alright producer  Dana Brunetti wrote on Facebook  production has confirmed that everyone  working on location in the South of  France is okay everyone has been  accounted for another sad day for France  and the world by Friday they'd resumed  work and Jamie and Dakota were spotted  looking somber onset yell James tweeted  about the attack calling it appalling